Tung tâm dự báo khi tượng thủy văn quốc gia cho biết ngày và đêm ngày 20 tháng 3,
cùng lối bác bộ có 1 người bởi người mưa rất to trên 1 trạm mili mẹ tập trung vào sẵn sớm
chờ tối và đêm các khu vực các của bác bộ thành quả và nằm bộ có 1 giọng giải giá
cục bộ 1 to trên sống 1 mili mẹ.
Mui cơ 1 cường xuất lớn vượt nằm 1 mili mẹ trong bác dở,
tìm mình lúc quách sợt lợt đất tại lại cho biệt biệt biệt gạo cảnh lặng sơn.
Từ đi ngày 20 mút đến ngày 20 tháng 3, bác bộ và thành quả tiếp tục có 1 vượt mưa tò,
cục bộ rất to.
Cái đoạn từ ngày 20 xa 5,5 tháng 3 có 1 giọng giải giá.
Cục bực ngày 1 đến hồi trong 2 ngày 20,5 tháng 3 có 1 giọng giọng
cục bộ 1 to về chêu tối.
Tại diễn vào ngày 20 xa 5,5 tháng 3.
Chuyên hại nằm chung bộ từ 20,5,5,5 tháng 3, cục có 1 giọng giải giá,
cục bộ 1 to.
Các khu vực khác chêu tối có 1 giọng giọng.